So a couple of years ago, Michael wrote a book about Meryl Streep. And it did fine, good reviews, hit the bestseller list for a couple weeks. And Michael did something that I guess is a normal thing to do if you've worked on anything for a year and a half including a book.
几年前，迈克尔写了一本关于梅丽尔·斯特里普的书。书卖得还不错，评论也挺好，还在畅销书榜上待了几周。迈克尔做了一件我觉得很正常的事，如果你为某件事忙活了一年半，包括写一本书，你也会这么做。
I would occasionally check its ratings on Amazon. And by occasionally, I mean all the time. And I have to say, most of them were great. There were a lot of people who really liked the book. Right now it has almost 300 customer ratings on Amazon.
我会偶尔在亚马逊上查看它的评分。所谓“偶尔”，意思就是我无时无刻不在看。我得说，大多数评价都很棒。很多人真心喜欢这本书。目前它在亚马逊上有近300条用户评价。
Let's just look it up. Do you have internet there?
我们查一下吧。你有网吗？
Yes. I have 295 customer ratings. 46% of them are five star ratings. 23% are four star ratings. So 2/3 of people who rated it loved it. So that's nice.
有。有295条用户评价。46%是五星好评。23%是四星评价。所以，2/3的评价者都喜欢这本书。那挺好的。
But it was those other people, the 8% who gave him one star, the 9% who give him two stars. Those are the people he found himself getting stuck on.
但正是那些人，那8%给了一星评价的人，还有那9%给了两星评价的人。这些人让他陷入了纠结。
I have to say, I'm not proud of any of this. I'm not proud of talking about this. I wish I was the kind of person who just floated in a cloud above my Amazon ratings, but I'm not. I mean, some of the things that people wrote on Amazon just kind of cut to the bone in this way.
我得说，我并不以此为荣。我不以此为荣谈论这些。我希望我能是一个高高在上、不受亚马逊评分影响的人，但我不是。我的意思是，人们在亚马逊上写下的一些话，真的会深深刺痛你。
If someone just says boring, a book critic isn't going to say boring. But if an average customer goes on Amazon and says, this book is boring, boring, boring, one star, I think it's worse than a smart book critic explaining why something did or didn't work. Boring, bland, hated it, no. There's one that just said no. And it just makes you feel terrible.
如果有人只是说“无聊”，书评人是不会说无聊的。但如果一个普通顾客上亚马逊评论说“这本书无聊、无聊、无聊，给一星”，我觉得这比一个聪明的书评人解释书哪里好或哪里不好更让人难受。“无聊、平淡、讨厌它、不行。”有一个评论就只写了“不行”。这真的让人感觉很糟糕。
So I would check my Amazon score an unhealthy number of times. And sometimes before I went to bed, which is a really bad idea, because then you would just drift off to sleep arguing with these people in your head.
所以我总是以一种不健康的高频率查看我的亚马逊得分。有时是在睡前，这真的非常糟糕，因为之后你就会在脑海里和这些人争吵，直到入睡。
But then Michael stumbled onto this strategy-- something he could do to deal with those feelings.
但后来迈克尔偶然发现了这个策略——一种他可以用来应对这些情绪的方法。
This has happened. I was just spending too much time thinking about who these people were. And at some point, I just clicked on one of their names.
确实发生了。我只是花太多时间去想这些人是谁了。在某一刻，我点击了其中一个人的名字。
One of the people who hated your book.
那个讨厌你书的人。
Yeah. And that brought me to everything else they had reviewed on Amazon. And I realized that when you do that, you see what they liked. And once I saw what some of these people loved on Amazon, it completely neutralized them.
是的。这让我看到了他们在亚马逊上评价过的其他所有东西。我意识到，当你这样做时，你会看到他们喜欢什么。一旦我看到这些人中有些人爱什么，它就完全消解了他们的影响。
So let's go through some of the ones that you saw.
那我们来看看你看过的一些评论吧。
OK. So Kathy gave me two stars. She says, disappointing. Too much detail about people other than Meryl Streep. And not enough about Meryl herself. What did Kathy like? A cupcake stand that comes in lavender with polka dots. Five stars. And she just writes, perfect.
好的。凯茜给了我两星。她说：“令人失望。关于梅丽尔·斯特里普以外的人的内容太多了。关于梅丽尔本人的内容太少。”凯茜喜欢什么？一个淡紫色圆点图案的纸杯蛋糕架。五星好评。她只写了：“完美。”
What's that say to you?
这说明了什么？
That she has enough cupcakes that she needs to arrange them on a cupcake stand in polka dots, and that makes her happy. My book cannot speak to that sort of-- let me try this again. Perfection to Kathy is this cupcake stand filled with cupcakes with polka dots. And my book did not give her that same feeling, and that's OK.
说明她有足够的纸杯蛋糕，需要摆在圆点图案的架子上，这让她感到快乐。我的书无法满足那种——让我再组织一下语言。对凯茜来说，完美就是这个摆满圆点图案纸杯蛋糕的架子。而我的书没能给她那种感觉，这没关系。
A reader had given him one star and said about his book, a lot of words, but not interesting. Gave five stars to bright red yarn. The person who gave him the one-word review no gave five stars and a rave to a tin kazoo.
有位读者给了他一星，评价他的书说：“废话连篇，没意思。”但给亮红色毛线打了五星。那个只留了一个词“不行”评论的人，给了锡制玩具卡祖笛五星好评。
The person who said, boring, boring, boring, and also, the author is so consumed with his lofty vocabulary that the reader falls asleep, gave a rave review to a book predicting the end of the world by 2015. A woman named Wendy gave one star, telling potential readers to move on. And what did she love?
那个说“无聊、无聊、无聊”，还说“作者沉迷于他那华丽的辞藻，让读者昏昏欲睡”的人，给一本预测2015年世界末日的书打了好评。一个叫温迪的女士给了一星，告诉潜在读者不要浪费时间。她喜欢什么？
OK, so Wendy gave five stars to an Amazon.com e-gift card, which struck me as nuts. Why is anyone rating Amazon gift cards on Amazon? It's like saying, yes, this $20 bill is worth $20. Why rate this thing? This thing couldn't possibly be good or bad.
好的，温迪给了一张亚马逊电子礼品卡五星好评，这让我觉得简直疯了。为什么有人要在亚马逊上给亚马逊礼品卡打分？这就像是在说，“没错，这张20美元的钞票确实值20美元。”为什么要给这个评分？这东西不可能有什么好坏之分。
Have you done the flip side of this? Have you looked up the people who loved your book to see what else they loved?
你试过反过来看看吗？你有没有查过那些喜欢你书的人，看看他们还喜欢什么？
No, I don't want to know anything more about them. They're angels.
不，我不想再了解他们了。他们是天使。
Well, we have done that. Let me read some of them to you. This is a woman who gave you five out of five stars. Interesting, she says. This book was well-written and very interesting. Meryl's life has been full of interesting people and experiences, and I enjoyed learning more about her.
好吧，我们查过了。让我读给你听。这是一位给了你五星好评的女士。“有趣，”她说。“这本书写得很好，非常有趣。梅丽尔的生活充满了有趣的人和经历，我很高兴能更多地了解她。”
She also loved, five out of five stars, the Game of Gnomes Garden Gnome. Throne for the throne room. Cracks me up every time I look at it. It's in my bathroom where my throne is. And here's a picture of the gnome.
她还给了“矮人游戏”花园矮人五星好评。“放在王座室的王座。每次看到它我都笑得不行。它就放在我浴室的王座旁边。”这是那个矮人的照片。
Ugh. Yeah. That's a gnome. Yeah. She puts this in her bathroom? It's in my bathroom where my throne-- she keeps this gnome in her bathroom.
呃。是的。那确实是个矮人。是的。她把它放在浴室里？“放在我浴室的王座旁边”——她把这个矮人放在浴室里。
And she gave it five out of five stars. And she also loved my book. I see what you're saying. It doesn't-- [LAUGHS] it's not great if you do it the other way around.
她给了它五星好评。她还喜欢我的书。我明白你的意思了。这并不——（笑）如果反过来做，感觉并不好。
OK, one more. This person, five out of five stars. He chronicles her relationships on-stage and off, giving us a clear, unique portrait of a professional. Also bought, not one, not two, but three Amazon gift cards.
好的，还有一个。这个人给了五星好评。“他记录了她在台前幕后的关系，为我们展示了一个职业人士清晰、独特的肖像。”还买了，不是一个，不是两个，而是三个亚马逊礼品卡。
Did she rate them?
她评价了吗？
She rated them. Five out of five stars.
她评价了。五星好评。
Don't tell me this. She's one of the Amazon gift card people? Just buy something. Buy something that you like. A cupcake stand, anything. Get a real thing and rate that. I'm sorry. Just why?
别告诉我这个。她也是那群亚马逊礼品卡评价者之一？去买点别的东西吧。买点你真正喜欢的东西。纸杯蛋糕架，什么都行。买个实实在在的东西去评价它。我很抱歉。到底为什么？
The way Michael sees it, the fact that every single thing on Amazon, every gift card, every garden gnome, every light bulb, and USB cord, and mop is measured against every book, every classic film, against every bit of journalism and fiction, against the Bible, and the Quran, and the Bhagavad Gita. All on the same five-point scale? It's perverse. Those things are different. And, of course, these kinds of reviews are everywhere.
在迈克尔看来，亚马逊上的每一样东西——每张礼品卡、每个花园矮人、每个灯泡、每根USB线和拖把——都要和每一本书、每部经典电影、每一篇新闻报道和小说、甚至和《圣经》、《古兰经》、《薄伽梵歌》放在一起衡量，都用同样的五分制评分，这真是荒谬。这些东西本质完全不同。当然，这种评论到处都是。
I mean, the way the world is now, there's just constant feedback about everything. When you take an Uber, you're asked to rate the Uber driver. We're just constantly leaving stars for things and leaving customer reviews. There's Yelp. Everyone is constantly assessing everything.
我的意思是，现在的世界就是这样，一切都在不断地被评价。当你打优步时，你会被要求给司机打分。我们一直在为各种事物打分并留下顾客评论。有Yelp。每个人都在不停地评估一切。
That's true. Everything. Here, for example, is a review of the Great Wall of China. One star. Too crowded. Too much climbing. Missed the greatness of it. It was a lot of steep climbing time. The Parthenon. One star. It was just a big bunch of columns that lack artistic taste.
确实如此。一切皆可评估。比如，这是对中国长城的评价。一星。“太挤了。爬得太累。错失了它的伟大之处。”那是一段很陡的攀登过程。帕台农神庙。一星。“只是一堆缺乏艺术品味的石柱。”
The Statue of Liberty. One star. Imagine a combination of prison and the worst airport security. If you want to feel embarrassed to be an American, then you can find it here. The Auschwitz concentration camp in Poland. One star. Total disgrace. There are no places to rest and reflect in peace. Surely, a sight that witnessed one of the largest mass murders in history deserves some space for reflection. Falling apart and not well-maintained.
自由女神像。一星。“想象一下监狱和最烂的机场安检的结合。如果你想为自己是个美国人感到尴尬，那就来这里吧。”波兰的奥斯威辛集中营。一星。“简直是耻辱。没有地方可以让人平静地休息和沉思。一个见证了历史上最大规模屠杀之一的景点，理应留出供人沉思的空间。正在倒塌，维护得不好。”
Well, from WBEZ Chicago. It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, in this world where now everyone is a critic, we visit places where reviews really should not be happening, and the story of somebody who very much does not want to leave a review, and someone else with the guts to say no to all the reviewers and haters of one of the most hated and worst reviewed films ever made. And you know what that is? No? Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目中，在这个人人都成了评论家的世界里，我们将走进那些本不该被评价的地方，讲述一个极力不想留下评论的人的故事，以及另一个有勇气对那些评论家和黑粉说“不”的人的故事，他对抗的是史上被黑得最惨、评价最差的电影之一。你知道那是什么吗？不知道？留下来听听吧。
Act 1, Their Eyes Weren't Watching God. So some things, it just feels wrong when they're reviewed. And I know I just read you a bunch like that, but want to hear one more? I know I do.
第一幕，《他们的眼睛盯着上帝》。有些东西，一旦被评价，就会感觉很不对劲。我知道我刚刚读了一堆这样的评论，但还想再听一个吗？我知道我想。
OK, this one is for the national park at Gettysburg, one of the pivotal battlegrounds in the Civil War. A woman from Miami gave it three stars and wrote, quote, I guess it's a little moving when you think about freedom and all that stuff, but really, it's a field.
好的，这个是关于葛底斯堡国家公园的，那是内战的关键战场之一。一位来自迈阿密的女士给了它三星评价，并写道，引述：“当你想到自由之类的东西时，我觉得它还是有点感人的，但说实话，它就是个田地。”
So another thing it can feel strange to review or read reviews of? Churches. One of our contributors, BA Parker learned this recently.
还有什么东西评价起来感觉很奇怪？教堂。我们的撰稿人BA·帕克最近就意识到了这一点。
I hadn't been to church-- any church-- in over a year, and I'd lost myself. I was miserable. My career was struggling. Relationships were strained. Little by little, I could see myself fading. And going to new church felt like a last resort. One of my roommates suggested a church that she'd been casually attending down the street-- First Corinthian Baptist Church.
我已经一年多没去过教堂了——任何教堂都没去过，我迷失了自我。我过得很糟糕。事业受挫。人际关系紧张。我一点点看着自己消沉下去。去一个新的教堂感觉像是最后的手段。我的一个室友建议去她平时偶尔会去的街上的那家——第一科林斯浸信会教堂。
[CAR HORN HONKS]
（汽车鸣笛声）
The first Sunday I went, I noticed a line half a block long, mostly of white people in cargo shorts waiting patiently behind a rope. An older black man with church flyers in his hand could see I was confused. He waved me toward the front door and greeted me, as if he were God's bouncer.
第一个星期天我去的时候，注意到门口排着半个街区的队，大多是穿着工装短裤的白人，正耐心地在绳子后面等着。一个手里拿着教堂传单的老黑人看出我很困惑，他把我引向正门并迎接我，就像他是上帝的保安一样。
It's a big place-- an old movie theater-- about 2,000 seats, marble floors, ushers, chandeliers. I walked down the crowded aisles and ended up sitting next to an elderly woman dressed in her Sunday best with this broad-brimmed regal hat. She reminded me of my great aunt Louise. When I slid into the pew, she hugged me. I didn't realize how much I needed that hug until my eyes started to tear up.
这是一个很大的地方——一个旧电影院——大约有2000个座位，大理石地板，领位员，吊灯。我走过拥挤的过道，最后坐在一位穿着周日礼服、戴着宽檐华丽帽子的老妇人旁边。她让我想起了我的大姨露易丝。当我坐进排椅时，她拥抱了我。我没意识到我有多需要那个拥抱，直到眼泪开始夺眶而出。
So just try and find this opportunity to just release and to relax the different parts of your body.
所以试着寻找这个机会，去释放和放松你身体的不同部位。
The service began with guided meditation and ended with communion and the choir singing Frankie Beverly and Maze's Happy Feelings.
仪式以引导冥想开始，以圣餐和唱诗班演唱弗兰基·贝弗利和Maze乐队的《快乐心情》结束。
(SINGING) And these happy feelin's, feel that happy feelin's.
（演唱）“这些快乐的心情，感受那快乐的心情。”
'70s R&B with the blood of Christ-- I thought, secular music? Lots of young black people? A pastor in jeans? I had found my home. There was only one problem. Above me, in the far back of the balcony, were tourists-- the white people in line from outside-- hundreds of them snapping selfies and gawking, hovering like a gaggle of anthropologists studying black Baptists in their natural habitat. Every expression of worship, every tear I shed, every hug I gave, every arm I outstretched to God, I felt like I was on display for them. I felt exposed.
70年代的R&B配上基督的宝血——我心想，世俗音乐？很多年轻的黑人？穿着牛仔裤的牧师？我找到了归宿。但只有一个问题。在我上方，阳台的最里面，是游客们——外面排队的那些白人——数百人在自拍和围观，像一群研究黑人浸信会信徒的人类学家，视这里为自然栖息地。每一次崇拜的表现，我流下的每一滴泪，我给出的每一个拥抱，我向神伸出的每一只手臂，我都觉得自己像是在给他们表演。我感到被暴露了。
Do you know [INAUDIBLE]?
你知道（听不清）吗？
There were baptisms. Some of the devout being baptized had overcome great odds. One, in particular, got the Holy Spirit and sobbed in the pool. Something unnamed and sacred had led them to that moment, and all I could think about were the white people upstairs taking pictures of someone's life-altering spiritual journey so they could share them over brunch. It was really messing with my worship.
有洗礼仪式。一些受洗的虔诚者克服了巨大的困难。特别是有一个人，获得了圣灵，在池子里啜泣。某种无法言说且神圣的东西引导他们到了那一刻，而我脑子里想的却是楼上的白人们在拍别人的改变人生的精神之旅，好让他们在早午餐时分享这些照片。这真的干扰了我的崇拜。
White tourists visiting black churches is a thing, especially in Harlem-- showing up for free music. It wasn't my first time hearing about it, but I had never experienced it before. Sure, there were some white congregants sprinkled throughout downstairs, but they're members. For lack of a better phrase, they're invited to the cookout. The tourists in the balcony-- they just want a song.
白人游客参观黑人教堂成了一种现象，尤其是在哈莱姆区——为了免费音乐而来。这不是我第一次听说，但我从未亲身体验过。当然，楼下也有稀疏的白人信徒，但他们是成员。用一个更恰当的说法，他们是被邀请参加烧烤派对的。而阳台上的游客——他们只是想要一首歌。
I kept going to this church every Sunday, but I felt like I was unwillingly participating in their gospel concert. I struggled to focus on what mattered to me most, my own relationship with the big guy upstairs.
我每周都去那个教堂，但我感觉自己成了他们福音音乐会的非自愿参与者。我很难专注于我最看重的事情，即我与上帝个人的关系。
I was navigating all that when I learned about the reviews. Tourists critique the church online, writing reviews on websites like Yelp and TripAdvisor. Some were fine, saying they loved the experience and thanked the church for welcoming outsiders. Others were not so nice.
我就是在这种情况下听说了那些评论。游客们在网上评价教堂，在Yelp和猫途鹰之类的网站上写评论。有些还可以，说他们很喜欢这种体验，感谢教堂对局外人的欢迎。其他的就没那么客气了。
Quote, "The music was loud, repetitive, and vacuous. Church is to elevate us to God, not bring him to human level." Two stars. From France, "This is a scam. The children singing are circus animals." One star. From Italy, "Don't choose this place if you are expecting the gospel style of Sister Act." One star.
引述：“音乐又吵、又重复、又空洞。去教堂是为了升华我们对上帝的信仰，而不是把他降到人类的水平。”两星。来自法国的评价：“这是一个骗局。唱歌的孩子们就像马戏团里的动物。”一星。来自意大利的评价：“如果你期待《修女也疯狂》那种风格的福音音乐，那就别选这个地方。”一星。
And this one is meant to be a compliment, but I bristled. From Spain, "I will definitely repeat this experience if I go back to New York. Do not be afraid to go to Harlem on your own. A lot of white people live there." Four stars. Our worship was being graded on a gentrified curve. I got angry.
还有一个本意是赞美，但我听了很不舒服。来自西班牙：“如果我再回纽约，我一定会再来体验一次。不要害怕独自去哈莱姆。有很多白人住在那儿。”四星。我们的崇拜正被一种“绅士化”的准则评级。我很生气。
I don't like the tourists, but I do love the church. It has the familiarity and the warmth that I grew up with, but none of the conservative, intolerant baggage, the kind that's hesitant to let women on deacon boards and has strict dress codes. My old church was more insular, more of an old-school black Baptist space.
我不喜欢那些游客，但我爱这个教堂。它有我从小习惯的熟悉感和温暖，却没有任何保守、不宽容的包袱，没有那种犹豫着不让女性进入执事委员会、有着严格着装要求的陈旧规矩。我以前的教堂更封闭，更像是那种老派的黑人浸信会空间。
If you saw a white person during service, it required a whole quizzical discussion in the car ride home. Were they lost? Were they someone's special friend? FCBC had none of that, and I found it liberating. So I kept going to the church. I was going to make the best of it, but it wasn't easy.
如果你在礼拜时看到一个白人，回家路上的车里就会展开一场关于“他们是不是迷路了？他们是谁的特殊朋友？”的困惑讨论。FCBC没有那些，我觉得这很自由。所以我继续去那个教堂。我打算充分利用它，但这并不容易。
One recent Sunday at church, engrossed in a 15-minute rendition of "The Blood Will Never Lose Its Power," I swayed to the song and meditatively mouthed the words with the choir over and over again. I was losing myself and feeling God's presence when, out of the corner of my eye, I noticed it-- the glowing of phones in the dark, the older European man with the selfie stick, the backpack-laden tourists stepping out before the sermon, three or four at a time.
最近的一个星期天在教堂，沉浸在15分钟的《宝血永不失去力量》的演唱中，我随着音乐摇摆，不断地与唱诗班一起冥想般地跟着对口型。我正沉浸其中，感受着上帝的临在，这时，用眼角的余光，我注意到了——黑暗中手机亮光，拿着自拍杆的年长的欧洲男人，在讲道结束前就准备溜走的人，三个或四个一批地走着。
--every single week, we want to just say welcome, welcome, welcome. We hope that you feel the power of God. We hope that you feel that there is a shift happening in your life as well, and that you can begin to take that shift all across the globe to your own homes. And so FCBC, at this time, let us give our guests a warm welcome. Let's give them a hug and show them some love. Amen.
“……每周我们都想说欢迎，欢迎，欢迎。我们希望你们能感受到上帝的力量。我们希望你们能感觉到你们的生活也正在发生转变，并且你们可以将这种转变带回你们全球各地的家中。所以FCBC，现在，让我们给我们的客人们热烈的欢迎。让我们给他们一个拥抱，向他们展现我们的爱。阿门。”
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
We hugged the visitors, as the church instructs us to do, during the welcome. And immediately afterwards, over 45 tourists upped and walked out before the sermon had even begun. And all I could think was, the audacity. So rude.
在欢迎环节，按照教堂的指示，我们拥抱了来访者。紧接着，45名以上的游客还没等讲道开始就站起来走了。我满脑子想的都是：这太无礼了。太粗鲁了。
And you've got to get up every morning and let the enemy know that you can't have my joy today. It belongs to me. Look at your neighbor and tell them, neighbor, I [INAUDIBLE].
“你每天早上都要起来，让仇敌知道你今天不能夺走我的喜乐。它是属于我的。看看你的邻居，告诉他们，邻居，我（听不清）。”
Listening to the sermon, I felt torn and distracted by the tourists. Why do they have to be there at all? Why do I care so much? I asked other congregants if having the tourists there ever made them feel uncomfortable, if they thought it was a bit odd, if they ever got self-conscious, or if it was only me. One thought the tourists were fabulous. Another said they didn't think about it. One woman said my not wanting them there was blasphemous.
听着讲道，我感到被撕裂，被游客们分散了注意力。他们为什么非要来这儿？我为什么要在意这么多？我问其他信徒，有游客在场是否让他们感到不舒服，是否觉得这有点怪，是否会感到局促，还是只有我一个人这样。一个人认为游客们很棒。另一个人说他们从没想过这些。一位女士说我不想让他们来是亵渎神灵。
So yeah, it seems like it was only me. It was confusing. Yes, I don't want the tourists there. But what kind of Christian am I to be hating on people during a church service? So I went to the head of the church-- my pastor, Pastor Mike Walrund-- to ask, why are these tourists here? Why are we letting this happen? And how am I supposed to deal with it and see past it?
好吧，看起来确实只有我一个人这样。这让人困惑。没错，我不想游客来。但作为一个基督徒，在教堂礼拜时讨厌别人，这算什么？所以我去了教堂的负责人那里——我的牧师，迈克·沃尔伦德牧师——去问：为什么这些游客在这里？我们为什么要让这种事发生？我该怎么去处理和看开它？
Why do you want the tourists there?
你为什么想让游客来？
I don't necessarily think about wanting tourists. We welcome everyone. So I don't necessarily say, well, I want these people here, and I want those people. Whoever comes, I celebrate. And then we're open. So I know there are churches that have said that they wouldn't allow tourists, or, when they do, make the tourists pay a bunch of money to come in. They'll take their money, right? But for us, I think everyone here is a tourist.
我并不一定想什么“想要”游客。我们欢迎每一个人。所以我不一定会说，嗯，我想要这些人在这里，或者想要那些人。无论谁来，我都欢迎。我们持开放态度。我知道有些教堂说他们不准游客进入，或者当他们准许时，会让游客交一大笔钱才能进来。他们会收他们的钱，对吧？但对我来说，我觉得这里的每个人都是游客。
And like I tell you, I know the power of the word, and how the word can spread, and how people can take what they hear here, and it goes places. Your words will go to places that you will never go. And so that's how I always look at it. It is an opportunity to spread this word, and to get the message out that we're doing, and expand and broaden our reach. And sometimes, the people who expand and broaden our reach happen to be tourists.
就像我告诉你们的，我知道道的力量，知道这道如何传播，知道人们如何带走他们在这里听到的东西，并传播到远方。你的话会传到你永远不会去的地方。所以这就是我一直看待它的方式。这是一个传播这道、传达我们要传的信息、扩大和拓宽我们影响力的机会。有时候，那些扩大和拓宽我们影响力的人恰好就是游客。
Pastor Mike also said my sensitivity about the tourists, though he understands it, is generationally different than the older black congregants, who perceive the optics of having, essentially, a section for white people in a more ironic way than I do.
迈克牧师还说，我对游客的敏感，尽管他能理解，但在代际上与年长的黑人信徒不同，他们以一种比我更讽刺的方式看待在教堂里设置白人专区的视觉观感。
And they see a lot of tourists who are predominantly white in the balcony, because they know history enough to know that that's different, because, historically, it was flipped. Well, that was a practice in this country for years, where African-Americans had to sit in the balcony and could not worship with white people, because African-Americans were relegated to the balcony and could not engage with worship experience.
他们看到阳台上有许多以白人为主的游客，因为他们熟知历史，知道那感觉不同，因为从历史上看，情况是颠倒的。嗯，在这个国家，非裔美国人必须坐在阳台，不能与白人一起崇拜，因为非裔美国人被贬低到阳台，不能参与崇拜体验，这种情况已经存在多年了。
He knows the tourists are not what everyone wants. But what Pastor Mike wants me to know is that the tourists aren't just in the balcony, and they aren't just white. He says the balcony is for large groups of visitors, and they just happen to be European. He insists the largest number of tourists in the church aren't white. They're black. They blend in, sitting down on the main floor with all of us. So he puts it back to me. Is my problem with tourists or with white tourists? It's white tourists. He tells me, don't be prejudiced. It's wrong.
他知道游客不是每个人都想要的。但迈克牧师想让我知道的是，游客不仅仅在阳台上，他们也不仅仅是白人。他说阳台是给大批参观者的，而他们恰好是欧洲人。他坚持说，教堂里人数最多的游客不是白人，而是黑人。他们融入其中，坐在主楼层和我们大家一起。所以他把问题反抛给我：我的问题是针对游客，还是针对白人游客？是白人游客。他告诉我，不要有偏见。这是错的。
If we start looking at people who enter our spaces of worship, and because they're strangers treating them-- and because they're obviously strangers because of the racial dimension, then we undermine ourselves as followers of the teachings of Jesus and as people who call ourselves Christians.
如果我们开始审视进入我们崇拜场所的人，仅仅因为他们是陌生人——并且因为种族因素显而易见地把他们当作陌生人对待，那么我们就在作为耶稣教导的追随者和自称基督徒的人，在摧毁我们自己。
And I know that. But I can't stop feeling exposed. It looks the way it looks-- white people staring down on us praising God. The optics are all wrong.
我知道这些。但我无法停止感到被暴露。这看起来就是那个样子——白人在俯视我们赞美上帝。视觉观感完全错了。
It's I guess because I feel a certain protectiveness because of the shared experience that we have as black people and I feel protectiveness of you.
我想是因为我有一种保护欲，因为我们作为黑人有着共同的经历，而且我对你有一种保护欲。
We are intoxicated by perceptions, and image, and optics. And optics communicate no substance. So the question is not what it appears. The question is, do I care? That's the real question. And the answer is, no. I can't be consumed with people's perceptions of our space, because then I'll be trying to curtail what we do to respond to people's perceptions. No, that's not who we're called to be. I can't. So the optics of it mean nothing to me.
我们被认知、形象和视觉观感所麻痹。而观感传达不出本质。所以问题不在于它看起来像什么。问题是，我在乎吗？这才是真正的问题。答案是，不。我不能被别人对我们空间的看法所消耗，因为那样我就要改变我们的行为来回应人们的看法。不，我们被呼召并不是要成为那样的人。我不能。所以这些视觉观感对我来说毫无意义。
Pastor Mike knows what it looks like, making white people sit in a sectioned-off area. He knows it's provocative. But he's fine with it. It's not intended to be punishment. But that doesn't answer my question. How do I block them out when I worship?
迈克牧师知道让白人坐在一个隔离区域看起来像什么。他知道这会引起争议。但他没问题。这本意并不是惩罚。但这并没有回答我的问题。当我在礼拜时，我该怎么把他们屏蔽掉？
When I worship, I engage God. I could care if it was one person or 2,000. I don't care who's present. It's about me. And that moment is a sacred space. I do it in the presence of others who are celebrating God, but that's a sacred moment for me. And my sacred moment cannot be intruded upon by anybody, tourists or not.
当我在崇拜时，我与上帝交流。我才不在乎是一个人还是两千人。我不在乎谁在场。这是关于我自己的。那一刻是神圣的空间。我在其他赞美上帝的人的陪伴下进行，但那对我来说是一个神圣的时刻。而我的神圣时刻不能被任何人打扰，无论是不是游客。
Pastor Mike's words helped a little. I'm aspiring to a new level of clarity in my worship-- more like his. But I'm still working on myself. I'm not there yet. I still don't want people there staring at us like we're all some source of entertainment for them. But going forward, I'm going to try to do what I can to get the tourists out of my mind and out of my way, starting with this review of FCBC from me, Parker from Baltimore.
迈克牧师的话有一点帮助。我正渴望在我的崇拜中达到一个新的清晰境界——更像他的境界。但我还在努力提升自己。还没到那一步。我依然不想让人们在那里盯着我们，就像我们是什么娱乐来源一样。但未来，我会努力做我能做的，把游客从我的脑海中、从我的路途中赶走，先从我这个对FCBC的评论开始，我是来自巴尔的摩的帕克。
"Went to FCBC one Sunday, and then kept coming back. Helped me when I really needed it. And if you're a tourist reading this and wonder what the black congregants think of you taking photos during baptisms and baby christenings, I, for one, don't love it. Please stop. Help make a great church better." Five stars.
“一个星期天去了FCBC，然后就一直回来。在我真正需要的时候帮助了我。如果你是一个正在读这篇文章的游客，并且好奇黑人信徒在你们洗礼和婴儿洗礼期间拍照有什么想法，我个人并不喜欢它。请停止。帮助让一个伟大的教堂变得更好。”五星。
B.A. Parker in New York. If you google the First Corinthian Baptist Church, it'll take you to their website-- FCBC NYC-- where there are videos of sermons, and guest speakers, and all sorts of other stuff. I think we are not going to give you their address.
纽约的B.A.·帕克。如果你在谷歌上搜索第一科林斯浸信会教堂，它会带你到他们的网站——FCBC NYC——上面有讲道视频、嘉宾演讲以及各种各样的东西。我想我们不会把他们的地址给你。
Coming up, a story about somebody who is studiously trying not to give a review. I think it's not too much to say that his very freedom depends on that. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一个关于某个人正刻苦地试图不给出一份评价的故事。我觉得说他的自由很大程度上取决于此并不为过。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续，稍后回来。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Everyone's a Critic-- tales from a world where everything gets rated and reviewed. We've arrived at Act Two of our show, Act Two, Mr. Chen Goes to Wuhan. So this next story is about somebody who's studiously trying not to be a critic because of where he lives and what he's doing.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题“人人都是评论家”——讲述一个一切皆可评分和评价的世界中的故事。我们已经到了节目的第二幕，第二幕，陈先生去武汉。所以接下来的这个故事是关于一个刻苦地试图不成为评论家的人，因为他的居住地和他正在做的事情。
His name is Chen Cho Qiushi, and he lives in China. And he's been going around that country to the most controversial places-- places that are the most sensitive, as far as the Chinese government is concerned, including the city at the center of the coronavirus epidemic. Chen shows up, looks around, gathers information, and posts videos online with the truth of what he's found, which is risky, because China, of course, is an authoritarian country with a tight grip on information and total control over the media.
他的名字叫陈秋实，他住在北京。他一直在中国国内去往最具争议的地方——对中国政府而言最敏感的地方，包括处于新冠病毒流行中心的那座城市。陈秋实出现在那里，四处看看，收集信息，并将视频发到网上，讲述他所发现的真相，这很冒险，因为中国显然是一个威权国家，对信息有着严密的控制，并对媒体拥有绝对的掌控权。
The government's version of reality is what's reported in newspapers, on TV, and online. Inside China, it's hard to get foreign news sources, which is why, when Chen does all this, he tries very hard not to be a critic, not to venture an opinion. Reporter Jiayang Fan has been watching his videos with fascination for a while now.
政府版本的现实就是报纸、电视和网络上报道的那些。在中国国内，很难获得国外的消息来源，这就是为什么当陈秋实做这一切时，他非常努力地不成为一个评论家，不去表达意见。记者樊佳阳关注他的视频已经有一阵子了，感到很着迷。
I've been writing about China for years. I'm from there, and I've never seen anyone like Chen. This guy wasn't a professional reporter or political activist, as far as I know. He was just a guy from the mainland who read about the Hong Kong protests in the state papers and wondered, is that the whole story? What's really happening? And went to see for himself.
我写关于中国的文章已经很多年了。我来自那里，但我从未见过像陈秋实这样的人。据我所知，这家伙不是职业记者，也不是政治活动家。他只是一个来自中国内地的人，在官方报纸上读到了关于香港抗议活动的报道，然后想：这是故事的全貌吗？到底发生了什么？于是就亲自去看了一看。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
In this video, shot on the waterfront in Hong Kong, he's saying, "I want to see, with my naked eye, what's happening on the ground. I want to bear witness to the stories of the people on the ground." Chen's a talented talker, a 30-something guy with very expressive eyebrows. He's running all over the city in a yellow press vest he bought after he saw online that reporters wore them at protests.
在这个视频里，拍摄于香港滨海区，他说：“我想用我自己的肉眼去看，地平线上到底发生了什么。我想亲眼见证那些身处一线的人们的故事。”陈秋实是个天才的演讲者，一个30多岁的家伙，有着非常有表现力的眉毛。他穿着一件黄色新闻背心在城市里到处跑，那是在他网上看到记者们在抗议活动中穿这种背心后买的。
He's a lawyer who is into public speaking. A couple years back, he was in a reality TV speech competition, kind of like The Voice for nerds. That was his first brush with being a public person. His videos sort of feel like an extension of that speech competition. Instead of talking and explaining things on a stage, he's doing it out in the world.
他是一名对公众演讲感兴趣的律师。几年前，他参加了一个真人秀演讲比赛，有点像书呆子版的《美国之声》。那是他第一次触碰到公众人物的门槛。他的视频感觉像是那场演讲比赛的延伸。他不是在舞台上谈话和解释事情，而是在现实世界中这样做。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
In Hong Kong, Chen's coverage is painstakingly neutral. He goes to a pro-democracy protest, and also to a pro-Beijing rally. At both, he tries to estimate the crowd size and the age of the participants. He spends one video explaining subtle differences between factions of the movement. At no point does he hint at his own political stance. In fact, he emphasizes that he will not take a side.
在香港，陈秋实的报道是苦心经营的客观中立。他去参加民主抗议活动，也去参加支持北京的集会。在这两场活动中，他都试图估算人群规模和参与者的年龄。他花了一段视频解释该运动各派系之间微妙的区别。在任何时候，他都没有流露自己的政治立场。事实上，他强调他不会偏袒任何一方。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
He's saying, "I will try my best to put my prejudice aside and stay neutral about what I see." This neutrality thing is important, because, across China, most people support, or at least go along with, the party. They're skeptical of people who defy the government. Those people are seen as troublemakers and dissidents. They're regarded with suspicion, and their ideas are easily dismissed.
他说：“我会尽我最大的努力把偏见放在一边，对我所看到的保持中立。”这种中立很重要，因为在中国各地，大多数人都支持，或者至少顺从党。他们对反抗政府的人持怀疑态度。这些人被视为麻烦制造者和异见人士。他们被怀疑的眼光审视，他们的观点也很容易被驳回。
Chen didn't want to be dismissed. But what's more, he didn't act like a dissident. He quotes a state newspaper as inspiration for his trip and declares his loyalty to China. Watching him, he seemed genuinely curious about the things he was witnessing and completely sincere.
陈秋实不想被驳回。更重要的是，他表现得不像一个异见人士。他引用官方报纸作为他旅行的灵感，并宣称他效忠中国。看着他，他似乎对他所目睹的事情感到由衷的好奇，而且完全真诚。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
His videos from Hong Kong reached hundreds of thousands of people on Weibo, the Chinese version of Twitter. As soon as I saw them, I wanted to talk to him, though I wasn't sure how hard he would be to reach because his last video hinted that he might be in trouble.
他在香港拍摄的视频在微博上吸引了数十万人。我一看到它们就想跟他谈谈，尽管我不确定联系他会有多难，因为他上一段视频暗示他可能遇到了麻烦。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
It's shot from the airport. In it, he says the Chinese Bar Association, the Public Security Bureau, and the Ministry of Justice have all called him telling him to come back and stop this nonsense. At one point, he holds up his law license, saying he knows he may very well lose it after these three days in Hong Kong. Once he got home, all of his social media accounts were deleted, and his videos were purged from the Chinese internet. But he wasn't hard to reach.
这段是在机场拍的。在视频中，他说中国律师协会、公安局和司法部都给他打了电话，让他回去，停止这些胡闹。在某一刻，他举起了他的律师执照，说他知道在香港这三天后，他很可能失去它。他一回到家，他所有的社交媒体账号都被删除了，他的视频也被中国互联网清除。但他并不难联系。
When I got his number, he picked up right away. He was little flustered. He explained he was in the middle of a family situation. His mom found out about his reporting adventure from a cousin's classmate, freaked out, and traveled hundreds of miles to his doorstep, and moved in with him. He was funny about it.
当我拿到他的号码时，他很快就接了。他有点惊慌失措。他解释说他正处于某种家庭情况中。他妈妈通过亲戚的同学知道了他的报道冒险，被吓坏了，大老远跑来他家门口，直接住了下来。说起这个他觉得挺好笑的。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
We've been living together for over 20 days, and it's been kind of awkward. She follows me wherever I go. Just now, when I came down to take your call, she ran after me to the elevator. That's why I was kind of bummed when I answered.
我们在一起住了20多天了，感觉有点尴尬。我走到哪她跟到哪。刚才我下来接你电话的时候，她还追到电梯口。所以我接电话时心情有点沮丧。
Chen's mother was there to save him from himself, he explained, less he decided to go off once again and try something reckless. His mom kept watch on him 24/7. During the day, she did not let him out of her sight. At night, they shared his twin-sized bed.
陈秋实的母亲来是为了从他自己手中救下他，他解释道，免得他再次冲动尝试什么鲁莽的事情。他妈妈24小时监控他。白天，她不让他离开视线。晚上，他们挤在一张单人床上。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Yeah, I'm uncomfortable, but there's no way around it. It's the only way she feels safe.
是的，我很不舒服，但没别的办法。这是她唯一能感到安全的方式。
This all sounded very familiar to me. I have a mother like this, too. Chen's 34, just a year younger than me. We both grew up as only children in '80s China. Our mothers have both expressed to us that if anything were to happen to us, they would lose the very will to live.
这一切对我来说听起来非常熟悉。我也有一个这样的母亲。陈秋实34岁，只比我小一岁。我们都是80年代中国出生的一代独生子女。我们的母亲都向我们表达过，如果我们要是有什么不测，她们将失去活下去的动力。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
The hardest thing to deal with is the effects on my family and loved ones.
最难处理的事情就是对我的家人和爱人的影响。
That's what pulled Chen back from his trip to Hong Kong-- not because he was worried for himself, but because of the risk of complicating other people's lives. China was safe, he told me. But he'd been let go from his law firm, and he had been interrogated repeatedly. On the day he arrived back from Hong Kong, he'd been grilled for eight hours straight. He had to run through every detail of where he was each day.
这就是把陈秋实从香港拉回来的原因——不是因为他担心自己，而是因为让别人生活变得复杂的风险。他说，中国是安全的。但他已经被律师事务所解雇了，并多次受到审讯。在他从香港回来的那天，他被连续审讯了八个小时。他不得不仔细回顾每一天他身处何处的细节。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Then they took me through reeducation on the policies of the Communist Party, how the government has a certain perspective about Hong Kong. They said, because I was a lawyer, I should support the Communist Party and its decisions, and I shouldn't go against them, shouldn't go to certain places, and so on, and so on.
然后他们对他进行了关于共产党政策的再教育，关于政府对香港有着怎样的视角。他们说，因为我是一名律师，我应该支持党和它的决定，我不应该违抗他们，不应该去某些地方，等等，等等。
Then they tried another tactic.
然后他们换了一种策略。
Then they took on a very parental tone. They said, we're doing this because we care about you.
然后他们换成了一种非常家长式的语气。他们说：“我们这样做是因为我们关心你。”
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
You're a young guy with a bright future ahead of you. You've won so many speech and debate prizes when you were young. You've appeared in so many TV shows. You've posted such great content and videos to social media. We think you're really talented. We're lucky to have such a great local lawyer.
你是个有光明前途的年轻人。你年轻时赢过这么多演讲和辩论比赛。你上过那么多电视节目。你还在社交媒体上发过那么多很棒的内容和视频。我们觉得你真的很有天赋。能有这样一位出色的本地律师是我们的幸运。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
But then you went to Hong Kong and jeopardized all of that.
但是你去了香港，把这一切都置于危险之中。
And finally, they drove it home.
最后，他们直击重点。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Are you married? Look at you. You're over 30, and you haven't married yet. Your parents must be so anxious. People need to prioritize families. You need to start a family and have kids. That's the only way to have a normal life. So don't let your parents worry. You need to hurry up and get that straightened out.
你结婚了吗？看看你。你都过30了，还没结婚。你父母一定很焦虑。人们需要优先考虑家庭。你需要组建家庭生孩子。这是拥有正常生活的唯一方式。所以别让父母担心。你需要赶快把这件事理顺。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
So for a full day, from 9:00 in the morning to 5:00 in the evening, it would just be that. They were using different tactics like that, trying to tell me why going to Hong Kong was wrong.
所以整整一天，从早上9点到晚上5点，就是这些。他们使用各种不同的策略，试图告诉我为什么去香港是错误的。
But Chen wasn't that troubled by the questioning. He had been scrupulously neutral when he was in Hong Kong, and he believed that would protect him, and things would not get worse than this.
但陈秋实并没有被这些审问弄得太困扰。他在香港时一直保持着审慎的中立，他相信那会保护他，事情不会比这更糟糕了。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
So I think it's because I worked so hard to be neutral and to not support or lean towards one side or the other that I was able to stay safe.
所以我觉得这是因为我努力保持中立，不去支持或偏向哪一方，所以我能够保持安全。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
I asked him the question that had been on my mind all this time. Why did he do it?
我问了他一直在我脑海里的那个问题。为什么他要这样做？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
It's just a passion. Sometimes people say, oh, that was so brave of you. You've risked so much in the pursuit of truth. I hate that. This has nothing to do with bravery. It's just a hobby. You have guys out there who like watches. You have guys who like to fix up their cars, people who like to hike or to ski. This is my hobby. My hobby is engaging with and pursuing the news. It's just something I'm interested in.
这只是一种激情。有时候人们说，哦，你太勇敢了。你在追求真理的过程中冒了这么大险。我讨厌那样。这跟勇敢无关。这只是一个爱好。外面有人喜欢手表，有人喜欢修理汽车，有人喜欢徒步或滑雪。这是我的爱好。我的爱好是参与和追求新闻。这只是我感兴趣的事情。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
I can almost see him shrugging on the other side of the line. Chen sees himself as a curious guy collecting facts. He's not out to issue any kind of review. He's not trying to provoke or antagonize. The way he talks about his videos, it's like they're an intellectual exercise more than anything else. I'm surprised by how blasé he is about the project, given the cost to his regular life. I wonder if there's more to it, if his composure is a kind of armor-- the one thing he can control.
我几乎可以看到他在电话另一端耸肩。陈秋实把自己看作一个收集事实的充满好奇的人。他不是要去发表任何类型的评价。他不想挑衅或对抗。他谈论自己视频的方式，就像它们是一场智力练习多过其他任何事情。他对自己这个项目的态度之随意让我感到惊讶，考虑到他为此付出的代价。我想知道这背后是否有更多深意，他的沉着是否是一种盔甲——他唯一能掌控的东西。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
A few months later, in late January, I do a double take when I see a video that Chen posts from the train station in Wuhan. It's the city at the center of the coronavirus epidemic. Apparently, he had grabbed his selfie stick and hopped on the last train in as the government put the city on lockdown.
几个月后，一月下旬，当我看到陈秋实从武汉火车站发出的视频时，我甚至怀疑自己看错了。那是新冠病毒流行的中心城市。显然，他在政府封锁城市时，抓起自拍杆跳上了最后一列进去的火车。
It's startling that he's there, because access to the city has been severely restricted and heavily enforced. There are very few news sources on the ground at this time. No one dares to go outside, and many shops are closed. Chen is his usual energetic, high-spirited self, sneaking in jokes along with the information. He's bewildered by all the elderly people he saw on his trip who still weren't wearing face masks. Are they insane? He asks.
他在那里让人吃惊，因为进入这座城市的通道已经受到严格限制并被严密把守。这段时间地面上几乎没有新闻来源。没有人敢出门，许多商店都关门了。陈秋实还是那个充满能量、精神饱满的样子，他在信息中穿插着玩笑。他对旅途中看到那些仍然没戴口罩的老年人感到困惑。“他们疯了吗？”他问道。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
As their kids, we should force them to put on masks with the same energy they exude when pushing us to get married, he says. I watched the video on YouTube where Chen now has a channel and almost half a million followers. It's a website that's banned in China. You can only access it if you hop the firewall, which many people do. Some of them take his videos and spread them on Chinese social media.
他说，作为子女，我们应该用他们逼我们结婚时表现出的那种劲头，强迫他们戴上口罩。我在YouTube上看了视频，陈秋实现在那里有一个频道，有近50万粉丝。这是一个在中国被禁的网站。你必须翻墙才能访问，很多人都这样做。其中一些人把他的视频传播到中国社交媒体上。
Over the next few days, Chen goes on a tear through the city. He reports from the market, where a number of early cases surfaced, from a grocery store, from a funeral parlor, from the construction site for a hospital that's being built almost overnight.
在接下来的几天里，陈秋实疯狂地穿梭在城市各处。他从出现早期病例的市场、杂货店、殡仪馆、几乎在一夜之间建起来的医院工地进行了报道。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Outside a hospital one night, after hearing that the virus might be transmittable through the eyes, he films a video wearing a comically ill-fitting pair of swim goggles.
一天晚上在医院外，听闻病毒可能通过眼睛传播后，他戴着一副滑稽的、极不贴合的游泳护目镜拍摄了一段视频。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
There's a video shot from the front seat of a car, where he's chatting with the four people piled in with him, asking if they have enough food stocked up at home.
有一段视频是从汽车前排拍的，他正和挤在一起的四个人聊天，询问他们家里是否储备了足够的食物。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
The guy in the front has six months stored. He'd been preparing a long time for a food shortage, though he thought it would be from a trade war with America, not a virus.
副驾上的家伙储存了六个月的量。他为食物短缺做了很长时间的准备，尽管他以为那是中美贸易战引起的，而不是病毒。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Chen goofs around with the driver, practicing his Wuhan dialect.
陈秋实和司机开着玩笑，练习他的武汉话。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
But he also spends time doing long interviews with locals, drawing out intimate details of people's lives and their honest appraisals of the ongoing crisis. One night, Chen hosts a livestream interview with a middle aged man who goes by the pseudonym Ah Ming. Ah Ming's father had recently died.
但他还花时间对当地人进行了长时间的采访，挖掘出人们生活中的私密细节，以及他们对正在进行的危机的真实评价。一天晚上，陈秋实直播采访了一位中年男子，他用化名“阿明”。阿明的父亲最近去世了。
He tells Chen that his father had gone to the hospital for a routine physical in early January. He was in his 70s and healthy. He couldn't have known then that the hospital was also seeing patients infected with the mysterious pneumonia. Soon after, his father developed a fever that wouldn't go away.
他告诉陈秋实，他的父亲在1月初去医院做了一次常规体检。他70多岁，很健康。他当时不可能知道医院也正在接诊感染了那种神秘肺炎的病人。不久后，他的父亲就开始发烧，怎么也退不下去。
Ah Ming details the frantic search for treatment in the final weeks of his father's life, how, because there wasn't adequate equipment at the hospital, he had to spend a whole night pressing his father's leaky oxygen mask in place. He talks about the time a sudden lockdown at the hospital separated panicked family members, from their loved ones for 48 hours. It's difficult to listen to Ah Ming describe his father's last day.
阿明详细讲述了在他父亲生命最后几周里，那种绝望的求医过程：因为医院没有足够的设备，他不得不在医院度过整晚，用手压住父亲漏气的氧气面罩。他谈到了医院突然封锁隔离，让惊慌失措的家人与亲人失联48小时的那段时间。听着阿明描述父亲的最后一天让人感到很难受。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
I saw, with my own eyes, as his heart rate dropped from 120 to 0. I held his hand and saw this happen. It was painful. He was in a deep coma already. When they took off his oxygen mask, his mouth was still open. He suffocated to death.
我亲眼看着他的心率从120降到0。我握着他的手，目睹了这一切发生。太痛苦了。他当时已经深度昏迷。当他们取下氧气面罩时，他的嘴还是张着的。他窒息而死。
Ah Ming says he doesn't understand why the government didn't start alerting people back in December to wear masks. He wonders why the state media didn't cover the outbreak more thoroughly. If measures had been taken earlier, he says, my father wouldn't have died.
阿明说，他不明白政府为什么不在12月就开始提醒人们戴口罩。他纳闷为什么官媒没有更彻底地报道这次爆发。他说，如果早点采取措施，我的父亲就不会死。
A few days into Chen's trip, his own parents send him a video. They're sitting on a couch, looking like they're trying very hard not to mess up the complicated process of FaceTiming their son.
陈秋实武汉之行几天后，他自己的父母给他发了一段视频。他们坐在沙发上，看起来正努力想把视频通话这个复杂的过程弄好，不想出差错。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
We heard you went to Wuhan, he says. Apparently, Chen has, yet again, failed to inform his parents he was going on a reporting trip.
他说：“我们听说你去武汉了。”显然，陈秋实又一次没有告诉父母他要去进行报道旅行。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
His dad gruffly chides him, then tells him to do a good job and not to make trouble while he's there. His mom peers into the frame.
他爸爸粗鲁地责备了他几句，然后让他好好干，在那里别惹事。他妈妈凑进镜头里。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
We support you, she says. But be safe, OK?
她说：“我们支持你。但要注意安全，好吗？”
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Chen continues making videos for the next few days, and they're pretty grim. He posts one from inside a hospital, covertly filmed while pretending to call someone. The patients and their family members are bundled up in heavy winter coats and blankets. Almost everyone is attached to IV tubes and oxygen bottles.
接下来的几天，陈秋实继续制作视频，内容都很阴郁。他从一家医院内部发布了一段视频，是在假装打电话时偷偷拍摄的。病人和家属都穿着厚厚的冬衣，裹着毯子。几乎所有人都连着输液管和氧气瓶。
As his camera darts unsteadily through the room, there's a suffocating claustrophobia. In another video, Chen comes across an elderly patient in his wheelchair-- gray, limp, unmoving. A relative leans on the chair, holding his body up. As he films, Chen realizes the patient is dead.
当他的摄像机在房间里摇晃着扫视时，有一种令人窒息的幽闭恐惧感。在另一段视频中，陈秋实遇到了一位坐轮椅的老病人——脸色灰暗，瘫软不动。一名亲属靠在椅子上支撑着他的身体。拍摄时，陈秋实意识到那位病人已经死了。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
The woman explains, through her face mask, that the ambulance arrived too late to save him. Now she was trying to figure out what to do with the body.
那位女士隔着口罩解释说，救护车来得太晚，没能救活他。现在她正试图弄清楚该怎么处理遗体。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
There's a clip of a medical worker in a hospital parking lot. She's squatting by a car, crying into her phone. A colleague tells her it's not that serious, and she stands up, shaking with anger. I've been coughing for six days, she screams. Don't you dare tell me it's not serious.
有一段剪辑是一位医疗工作者在医院停车场拍的。她蹲在车边，对着电话痛哭。一位同事告诉她情况没那么严重，她站起身，愤怒得浑身发抖。“我咳嗽了六天了，”她尖叫道。“别再跟我说它不严重。”
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
For nearly a week, Chen has been posting videos from a city teetering on the edge of a breakdown. For nearly a week, he has watched from the sideline-- observing, listening, studiously reserving judgment. But then, on January 30, when he appears on screen, he isn't reporting. Instead--
近一个星期以来，陈秋实一直从一座摇摇欲坠、濒临崩溃的城市发布视频。近一个星期以来，他一直在场边观察——观察、倾听，刻苦地保留判断。但随后，在1月30日，当他出现在屏幕上时，他没有在报道。相反——
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
He's alone, hunched on a bed, wearing a tank top with what looks like a bedsheet wrapped around his shoulders. His face is pale, and his hair is uncombed.
他独自一人，蜷缩在床上，穿着一件背心，肩膀上裹着像床单一样的东西。他的脸色苍白，头发没梳。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
It's a 27-minute video, much longer than his regular ones. He plays several recap clips, talks about what he's seen. But he isn't his usual charismatic self. Something's off. When he's talking about the shortage of virus test kits, he seethes with contempt.
这是一个27分钟的视频，比他平时的长得多。他播放了几个回顾片段，谈论了他所见到的东西。但他不是那个平时充满魅力的自己。有什么不对劲。当他谈到病毒检测试剂盒的短缺时，他怒火中烧。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Did you hear that? There aren't enough test kits, he says. He counts off all of the dysfunctions he's witnessed in the past week, from the lack of transport to the shortage of supplies, the piles of unsorted donations, the overworked construction workers. The sheer volume of dysfunctions-- dysfunctions that gesture at larger failures of the government-- overwhelms Chen as he speaks. A jittery energy courses through him. He keeps trying to reset, will himself back into a state of collected calm. But it's not working.
“你们听到了吗？根本没有足够的检测试剂盒，”他说。他逐一列举了过去一周他目睹的所有混乱，从交通匮乏到物资短缺，成堆没整理的捐赠品，过度劳累的建筑工人。那纯粹的混乱数量——这些混乱指向了政府更大的失败——在他说话时压垮了陈秋实。一种神经质的能量在他体内游走。他不断尝试重置，强迫自己回到那种收集信息的冷静状态。但没用。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
OK, let's keep going.
好了，继续。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Sorry, my thoughts are really disorganized, because I'm starting to feel afraid. I'm genuinely starting to feel afraid.
对不起，我的思路真的很混乱，因为我开始感到害怕了。我真的开始感到害怕了。
The Ministry of Justice is after him-- calling him, he tells us. The police, too. They've been questioning his parents. Suddenly, the video takes a turn. The terror in his eyes hardens into something like rage.
司法部在追捕他——他告诉我们，他们打来电话。警察也是。他们一直在盘问他的父母。突然，视频发生了转变。他眼中的恐惧硬化成了一种愤怒。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
I am scared.
我很害怕。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
In front of me is the virus. Behind me is the power of China's law enforcement.
在我面前是病毒。在我身后是中国执法的力量。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
But I will persevere. As long as I am still alive, I'm going to keep reporting. I'm going to tell people what I see and what I hear.
但我会坚持下去。只要我还活着，我就会继续报道。我会告诉人们我所看到的和所听到的。
The last minute of the video feels like it's happening in slow motion. Chen's face, which is small and delicate, grows red, swollen, and crazed. They are excruciating seconds when his eyes fill up as he speaks through clenched teeth.
视频的最后几分钟感觉就像是在慢动作播放。陈秋实那张小而精致的脸变得通红、肿胀且狂乱。有几秒钟简直让人难以忍受，他咬着牙说话，眼中满是泪水。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
I'll just say it harshly.
我就直说了吧。
[BLEEP] [SPEAKING CHINESE]
（消音）（讲中文）
[BLEEP] you. I'm not even afraid of dying.
去你的。我甚至不怕死。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Do you think I'm afraid of you, Chinese Communist Party?
你以为我怕你们吗，中国共产党？
As the video ends, I realize I've stopped breathing. Chen's gone way past the line that he fought so hard not to cross. For as long as I had known him, being a respectable journalist, the kind he aspired to be, meant gathering facts without taking a side. But here in Wuhan, the facts must have added up to a reality so horrifying that a judgment was demanded.
视频结束时，我意识到自己已经停止呼吸了。陈秋实已经远远跨过了他曾拼命抗争不去跨越的那条线。只要我认识他，成为一名受人尊敬的记者，就是他所向往的那种，意味着在不偏袒任何一方的情况下收集事实。但在武汉，这些事实一定累积成了一种恐怖到需要做出判断的现实。
The next day, Chen posts a video apologizing for losing his cool. He goes back to reporter mode, standing outside the apartment of a family whose mother had died that morning to see how long it takes for the funeral home car to come. He's there for an hour. It never comes. He keeps reporting. A week later, a video shows up on Chen's timeline. It's not him. It's his mother.
第二天，陈秋实发布视频为失去冷静而道歉。他回到了记者模式，站在一个当天早上母亲去世的家庭公寓外，观察殡仪馆的车要多久才来。他在那儿待了一个小时。车从没来过。他继续报道。一周后，一段视频出现在陈秋实的时间线上。那不是他。是他母亲。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
She looks tired, and strands of her permed hair have fallen out of a loose ponytail. Her message is short. Chen has gone missing.
她看起来很疲惫，烫发的发丝从松散的马尾中掉落出来。她的信息很简短。陈秋实失踪了。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Help me. Please help me find Chen, she says. Please help.
“帮帮我。请帮我找到陈秋实，”她说。请帮帮我。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（讲中文）
Thank you.
谢谢。
Chen's been silent ever since then. He had given his social media passwords to friends in case he disappeared. One friend says that the police told his parents he'd been put in a medical quarantine. But people in quarantine are usually allowed to keep their phones and to stay in touch with people outside.
陈秋实从那时起就沉默了。他把社交媒体密码留给了朋友，以防万一他失踪。一位朋友说，警察告诉他父母他被送进了医疗隔离。但隔离中的人通常被允许保留手机并与外界保持联系。
No one's heard from Chen. It's been 22 days. Chen, who tried so strenuously to avoid becoming a political dissident, is now being treated like one. Of everything that's happened to him, I suspect what would pain Chen the most is the sight of his mother looking exhausted and afraid on video, pleading for his return.
没人有陈秋实的消息。已经22天了。陈秋实，那个曾经试图极力避免成为政治异见人士的人，现在正被当作那样对待。在他身上发生的所有事情中，我怀疑最让陈秋实痛苦的，莫过于在视频中看到他母亲神情憔悴、充满恐惧，恳求他回来的样子。
Jiayang Fan. She's a staff writer at The New Yorker.
樊佳阳。《纽约客》杂志的一名专栏作家。
Act Three, Must Love Cats. In a way, it was comforting that, in these dark and divisive times, there was one thing that fractured America could agree on this past year-- the movie Cats, based on the Andrew Lloyd Webber musical. And what everybody agreed was that it was trash.
第三幕，一定要爱猫。在某种程度上，在这个黑暗和分裂的时代，去年有一件事是四分五裂的美国能达成一致的，这令人感到安慰——那就是基于安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯音乐剧改编的电影《猫》。而每个人达成的一致就是：它是一堆垃圾。
Variety called it, quote, "A half-digested hairball of a movie." Collider said it, quote, "always feels like it's two seconds away from turning into a furry orgy in a dumpster." But one of the producers on our program, Lina Misitzis, found one of the very few people who felt differently than every living reviewer everywhere. Somebody who loved the film, which, actually, kind of became a problem in her house. Here's Lina.
《综艺》杂志称其为，引述：“一部半消化的毛球般的电影。”Collider网站称其为，引述：“感觉总是距离变成垃圾箱里的毛皮狂欢只差两秒钟。”但我们节目的制作人之一，莉娜·米西齐斯，找到了极少数与全球每一位在世影评人看法不同的人之一。一个热爱这部电影的人，这在她的家中其实变成了一个问题。这里是莉娜。
One of the many problems with Cats-- it doesn't really have a plot. But to EJ Dixon, it all makes perfect sense.
《猫》的众多问题之一——它根本没有剧情。但对EJ·狄克逊来说，这一切都说得通。
A bunch of cats, known as Jellicle cats, are auditioning to be the cat selected in sort of this cultic ritual to ascend to the Heaviside layer and be reborn. And so the show is just cats auditioning one after the other to be the one selected. They audition to die is basically what they do.
一群被称为“杰里科猫”的猫，正在试镜，争夺在某种邪教仪式中被选中，飞升至九重天（Heaviside layer）并重生的名额。所以这部剧就是猫一只接一只地试镜，看谁能被选中。说白了，它们试镜其实是为了去死。
Everything about the film that alienated people-- the weird CGI, the clumsy writing, the bizarre choreography, Jason Derulo-- none of it alienates EJ, which, honestly, doesn't surprise me. I've known EJ for years. She's a reporter at Rolling Stone. She's always struck me as dogged, someone who perpetually bears witness to the things other people don't really want to take seriously.
电影中所有让人们产生排斥感的元素——怪异的CGI、笨拙的剧本、怪诞的编舞、杰森·德鲁罗——都没有让EJ产生排斥，说实话，这并不让我惊讶。我认识EJ很多年了。她是《滚石》杂志的记者。她一直给我留下非常坚韧的印象，一个始终见证那些别人不想认真对待的事物的人。
Things that are widely misunderstood or understood differently-- I always want to know, what's the other story here? With Cats, it was very obvious, from the second that I saw it, this is going to be-- everybody's going to call this the worst movie ever made. But it's also just-- it's very earnest-- this sort of very simple, earnest story about the importance of inclusion.
“那些被广泛误解或被不同理解的事物——我总是想知道，这里的另一个故事是什么？”对于《猫》，我看到的第二眼就很明显，这会是——每个人都会称这是史上最烂的电影。但它同时也是——它非常真诚——这是一种关于包容重要性的、非常简单、真诚的故事。
Right. The cats learn a lesson about inclusion. Left that out.
没错。猫学到了关于包容的一课。把这点漏掉了。
Do you think you're being a contrarian?
你觉得你在唱反调吗？
No. I'm telling you. It's the same reason why I like musicals in general, because it's a way for me to sort of access the parts of myself that aren't sort of coded in cynicism and aren't automatically skeptical of everything and questioning everything. It's one of the ways that I can sort of experience the most earnest parts of myself, I guess.
不。我告诉你。这就是我喜欢音乐剧的同样原因，因为它是我接触自己内心那些并没有被愤世嫉俗编码，也不是自动对一切都表示怀疑、质疑部分的渠道。我想，这是我能体验自己内心最真诚部分的途径之一。
And when she saw Cats, that's how she responded to it-- earnestly. She couldn't get it out of her head.
而当她看到《猫》时，她就是这样回应它的——真诚地。她把它挥之不去。
The day after I saw Cats, my husband was taking a shower, and I went in, and I was like, I just need to talk to you about this.
看《猫》的第二天，我丈夫在洗澡，我走进去，说我只是需要和你谈谈这个。
Sorry. While he's in the shower, you go into the bathroom and start talking about Cats?
抱歉。他在洗澡的时候，你走进浴室开始谈论《猫》？
Yes. I was just talking at him about Cats. I was just like, and then this is what the CGI looked like, and here's what Old Deuteronomy did. And oh, my God. They had Ian McKellen lapping up milk. And at the end, Judi Dench breaks the fourth wall, and she says, a cat is not a dog. And I just need to tell you this, because I don't know how to make sense of it.
是的。我只是对他念叨《猫》。我就像是，“然后CGI看起来是这样，老戒律猫（Old Deuteronomy）做了这个。”噢，天哪。他们让伊恩·麦克莱恩趴着舔牛奶。最后，朱迪·丹奇打破了第四面墙，她说：“猫不是狗。”我只是需要告诉你这些，因为我不知道该怎么去理解它。
How often were you talking about it?
你多久谈论一次？
Constantly, constantly.
不停地，不停地。
How often was she talking about it?
她多久谈论一次？
Every day-- a lot of the time.
每一天——大部分时间。
This is EJ's husband, Alex. He looks like Greg Kinnear in the movies were Greg Kinnear is the good guy. Also, he looks really tired. But he's kind.
这是EJ的丈夫，亚历克斯。他在电影里看起来就像格雷格·金尼尔，就是格雷格·金尼尔演好人的那种电影。而且，他看起来真的很累。但他很善良。
Maybe after the first day or two. It became clear that this was a new obsession and it was here to stay.
可能第一两天后。很明显这是一场新的痴迷，而且它是要持续下去的。
And how did that make you feel?
这让你感觉如何？
Sorry for myself.
为我自己感到遗憾。
What are the kinds of things that she talks to you about when she talks about this movie?
当她跟你谈论这部电影时，她谈论的是什么样的事情？
Things about the producers that I can't even remember, how much money Andrew Lloyd Webber made, and how much more wealthy he is than Paul McCartney, which kind of astounded me.
一些我甚至记不住的制作人的事，安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯赚了多少钱，他比保罗·麦卡特尼富有得多，这让我相当震惊。
Is this the kind of thing where you immediately knew you didn't care about any of this?
你是那种会立刻知道自己根本不在乎这些的人吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
But was there a period of time where you were humoring her?
但有一段时间你是在迁就她吗？
Oh, for sure. I would definitely try to change the topic, play any other music that I could think of.
噢，当然。我绝对会试着转移话题，播放我能想到的任何其他音乐。
Play other music because EJ started playing the film soundtrack for the only other member of the family, their son Solomon, a three-year-old. And Solomon--
播放其他音乐，因为EJ开始为家庭的另一个成员——他们的儿子所罗门，一个三岁的孩子——播放电影原声带。而所罗门——
Loved it. Loved it immediately.
喜欢它。立刻就喜欢上了。
And how often do you guys listen to it?
你们多久听一次？
Almost every day. Alex basically went from living a life blissfully free of Cats to living in an all-Cats household all the time.
几乎每天。亚历克斯基本上从一种完全不用担心《猫》的生活，变成了生活在一个全天候、全都是《猫》的家庭里。
He'll just come up to me and say, dada, I want Jellicle cats, or, I want Rumpleteazer, or something like that. And now I have to know what that means.
他会直接跑到我面前说：“爸爸，我要杰里科猫，或者，我要Rumpleteazer（猫的名字）之类的话。”现在我必须得知道那是什么意思。
Alex could not understand his wife's love of this movie, which everyone else on the planet seemed to love to hate. Days went by, then weeks.
亚历克斯无法理解他妻子对这部电影的爱，而地球上的其他人似乎都爱恨交加。日子一天天过去，然后是几周。
He definitely was like, I can't hear about this anymore. And he has since said, multiple times, that it's ruined his life.
他绝对是那种“我再也听不到这个了”的状态。他后来已经多次表示，这毁了他的生活。
If Alex didn't want to talk about Cats anymore, EJ wanted to be a good partner. So she went somewhere else. She announced the new plan in a tweet. Quote, "My husband couldn't listen to me talking about it anymore, so I'm doing a podcast about the movie musical Cats. It's called PodCats."
如果亚历克斯不想再谈论《猫》了，EJ想做一个好伴侣。所以她去了别的地方。她在一条推文中宣布了新计划。引述：“我丈夫不能再听我谈论它了，所以我正在做一个关于音乐剧电影《猫》的播客。它叫PodCats。”
Are you blind when you're born?
你出生时是盲的吗？
Can you see in the dark?
你能看见黑暗中吗？
Would you--
你会——
She co-hosts it with her friend Dan.
她和她的朋友丹一起主持。
Can you say of your bite that it's worse than your bark? If you were and you are, you're the target audience for PodCats. We're Dan--
你能说你的咬人比你的吠声更糟吗？如果你是，并且你确实是，那你就是PodCats的目标听众。我们是丹——
And I'm EJ.
我是EJ。
It's pretty-- yeah, it's kind of deeply embarrassing that people are going to listen to the podcast and be like, who is this woman?
这太——是的，人们听到播客并心想“这个女人是谁？”确实挺让人尴尬的。
When you say podcast, do you mean This American Life?
当你提到播客时，你是说《美国生活》吗？
Both. Primarily PodCats-- PodCats the podcast.
两者都是。主要是PodCats——播客PodCats。
We're also going to answer all of your burning questions about cats, including but not limited to--
我们还将回答你们关于猫的所有燃烧问题，包括但不限于——
What's a Jellicle cat? What's a Jellicle cats-- cats-- cats-- cats-- cats-- cats-- cats-- cats-- cats-- cats--
什么是杰里科猫？什么是杰里科猫——猫——猫——猫——猫——猫——猫——猫——猫——猫。
Is it true that you told EJ that Cats is ruining your life?
你真的告诉过EJ《猫》正在毁了你的生活吗？
I've probably said that. We get so little time to ourselves now. We have a three-year-old, and we both work crazy hours. This is the way that you choose to spend your free time, by going to see Cats and making a podcast about it? How can you make that your free time?
我大概说过。我们现在留给自己的时间太少了。我们有一个三岁的孩子，我们俩的工作时间都很疯狂。这就是你选择花费空闲时间的方式，去看《猫》并制作关于它的播客？你怎么能把那作为你的空闲时间？
So Alex doesn't want to talk to his wife about this thing that she loves, which I get, except for one thing. He's passing all of this judgment, but he's never actually seen the movie. So I set it up for all three of us to go see Cats at the one theater within 234 miles that's still playing it.
所以亚历克斯不想和妻子谈论她喜欢的这个东西，我也能理解，除了有一点。他一直在进行所有的评判，但他从未真正看过这部电影。所以我安排我们三个人去234英里内唯一还在播放这部电影的影院看《猫》。
Are you excited?
你兴奋吗？
Let's do this.
咱们开始吧。
We get to the theater just after 9:00 and take three seats in the back-- EJ and Alex next to each other. I'm next to Alex. I figure the theater would be empty. It wasn't. All three of us take turns remarking on the surprisingly good turnout, which, including us, totals nine.
我们在9点过后到达影院，在后排选了三个座位——EJ和亚历克斯坐在一起。我坐在亚历克斯旁边。我本以为影院会是空的。但并没有。我们三个人轮流评论着惊人良好的上座率，包括我们在内总共九个人。
There are definitely more people than I thought there would be.
这里的人绝对比我想象的多。
Yeah.
是啊。
In front of us are four teenagers slouched in their seats. They're laughing throughout the previews, which makes me think they're probably stoned. EJ notices them, too.
在我们前面是四个瘫坐在座位上的青少年。他们在预告片期间一直笑，这让我觉得他们可能嗑了药。EJ也注意到了他们。
These people are not here for the right reason.
这些人来这里不是为了正确的原因。
The film opens with a burlap sack tossed in an alleyway, which, obviously, is full of alley cats. Dozens of them circle the disposed sack, hissing, also doing pirouettes. And just to be clear, by cats, I mean human adults with fur digitally attached to their skin. One of them rips open the still-moving bag, allowing whatever is inside of it to break free. And what it is inside of this bag-- also a cat.
电影开场是一个被扔进小巷里的麻布袋，显然，里面装满了流浪猫。几十只猫围着被丢弃的袋子，嘶叫着，还在做旋转动作。为了说清楚，猫指的就是身上数字化贴着皮毛的人类成年人。其中一只猫撕开了还在动的袋子，让里面的东西挣脱出来。而袋子里装的那个东西——也是一只猫。
[MEOW]
（猫叫）
Oh, no. Look what the cat dragged in.
噢，不。看看猫拖进了什么。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
（交叉的人声）
Stop, and you're talking around your bowl on an empty stomach.
停下，你正空着肚子在你的碗周围说话。
Look, I'm not going to pretend Cats isn't a train wreck. Alex covers his mouth with his hand, like he's hiding his abject horror. But then, about 15 minutes into the movie, when Rebel Wilson starts singing and dancing with a parade of cockroaches, I realized something. EJ and Alex are on a really good date. For most of the movie, they hold hands. Alex kisses EJ's palm three times, which coincides with the number of times she calls something the best part of the movie.
听着，我不会假装《猫》不是一场火车失事。亚历克斯用手捂住嘴，好像在隐藏他绝望的恐惧。但在电影开始大约15分钟后，当瑞贝尔·威尔森开始对着一群蟑螂唱歌跳舞时，我意识到了一些事情。EJ和亚历克斯正在进行一次非常好的约会。电影的大部分时间里，他们都牵着手。亚历克斯吻了EJ的手心三次，这和她三次称某事是“电影中最棒的部分”的次数不谋而合。
This is the best part. [INAUDIBLE]. This is the best part.
这是最棒的部分。（听不清）这是最棒的部分。
I think what makes this a good date has nothing to do with what they're doing, but, instead, with the fact that they're doing it together. When Judi Dench's Old Deuteronomy shows up, who, by the way, is, for some reason, wearing a fur coat atop her literal coat of fur, Alex hums along with the rest of the cats, who are there to welcome her, because, of course, he knows the music. It's been playing in his house nonstop for months.
我觉得让这次约会成功的原因与他们正在做的事情无关，而是因为他们正一起做这件事。当朱迪·丹奇饰演的老戒律猫出现时，顺便说一句，因为某种原因，她在自己毛皮大衣外面又穿了一件皮毛大衣，亚历克斯随着其他欢迎她的猫一起哼唱，因为，当然，他知道这段音乐。它已经在他家里连续几个月不停地播放了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
（音乐播放）
[INAUDIBLE]
（听不清）
[HUMMING]
（哼唱）
The movie ends just before midnight. EJ says they need to get home, back to their son and sitter. We split a cab, and I ask Alex how he liked this movie that, to quote him, has ruined his life?
电影在午夜前结束。EJ说他们需要回家，回到他们的儿子和保姆身边。我们拼了一辆出租车，我问亚历克斯，他觉得这部引用他话来说“毁了他生活”的电影怎么样？
I liked it a lot more than I thought I would, actually.
我其实比我想象中要喜欢它得多。
And why?
为什么？
I liked-- what's his name, EJ? The railway cat.
我喜欢——那家伙叫什么来着，EJ？铁路猫。
Skimbleshanks.
Skimbleshanks。
Skimbleshanks. Skimbleshanks killed it.
Skimbleshanks。Skimbleshanks太棒了。
So something you told me before we went in is that part of you really does think that EJ's kind of just being a contrarian in liking this movie. And I'm wondering if you still feel that way?
所以你在我们进去之前告诉我的一件事是，你内心一部分确实认为EJ只是因为唱反调才喜欢这部电影。我想知道你现在是否还是那种感觉？
I knew you would say that.
我知道你会这么说。
Do you still feel that way?
你还那样觉得吗？
No, I don't. I don't feel that way. And I think I kind of have an understanding. I can see how, despite it being a horrible movie, you can genuinely appreciate it. It just kind of feels good. It's kind of joyous. I don't know. And I'm kind of-- yeah, I'm eager to unpack this with you more, EJ.
不，我不觉得。我不那样觉得。我想我算是理解了。我能看出来，尽管它是一部烂电影，但你是如何真诚地欣赏它的。它让人感觉很不错。它有一种喜悦感。我不知道。而且我有点——是的，我很渴望和你进一步交流这个，EJ。
I think you're only going to feel that way for a limited period of time.
我觉得你只会那样感觉一段时间。
That's probably true.
那可能是真的。
When movies end, the lights are still dim, the credits roll, there's this moment. It's just before people start getting up, where everyone's quiet. It's like waking up from a dream. And then, suddenly, you check back into the reality of your own life. I figure, that's the moment I'm catching Alex in. The lights haven't totally gone back up yet. This is not how he really feels.
当电影结束，灯光仍然昏暗，演职员表滚动时，有这样一刻。在人们开始起身之前，每个人都很安静。就像从梦中醒来一样。然后，突然间，你回到了你自己生活的现实中。我想，我正好捕捉到了亚历克斯那个时刻。灯光还没完全亮起来。这并不是他真正感受到的东西。
But then, a week later, I get a text from EJ. She says that, last night, while she and her son were listening to Cats, Alex belted along with the same song I had caught him humming to at the movies. I think he's turned, she says.
但随后，一周后，我收到EJ的一条短信。她说，昨晚，当她和儿子在听《猫》时，亚历克斯随着我在电影院听到他哼唱的那首歌一起高声演唱。我想他已经转性了，她说。
Lina Misitzis is one of the producers of our show.
莉娜·米西齐斯是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced this week by Lina Misitzis. The people who put together today's show includes Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Dana Chivvis, Noor Gill, Damian Grave, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目本周由莉娜·米西齐斯制作。今天节目的幕后团队包括埃尔娜·贝克、埃马努埃莱·贝里、达纳·奇维斯、努尔·吉尔、达米安·格雷夫、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。管理编辑是黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。
A special thanks today to Emily Liu, Yian Zhou, Robert Du, John Lesley Morton, and Heaven Berhane. Our website-- thisamericanlife.org-- where you can listen to our archive of nearly 700 shows for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
今天特别感谢艾米丽·刘、周一安、罗伯特·杜、约翰·莱斯利·莫顿和海文·伯哈内。我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org——在那里你可以免费收听我们近700期节目的档案。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心PRX发送到各公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia. Whenever he comes to New York City, there's only one deli that he wants to go to for corned beef.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚。每当他来到纽约市，他只想去一家熟食店吃咸牛肉。
Cats, cats, cats, cats, cats, cats, cats, cats.
猫，猫，猫，猫，猫，猫，猫，猫，猫。
I'll have what he's having. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我要和他点一样的。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。